in five four three two one
what's up everybody to another episode
of the genius brain podcast we have Joe
back again he was missing because the
man caught the European whooping cough
ever caught on that baby man I've been
[ __ ] up for like literally almost two
weeks so long dude you were gone for a
minute well cuz I was dealing with the
bacterial infection that I didn't even
know I had you know who are people who
are competeing like I hope this will
didn't go out he [ __ ] again like I got
a strong [ __ ] immune system alright
and I was like I would dealt with the
cold in Europe and I dealt with all
kinds of [ __ ] and I was like nothing is
gonna take me down and I've been tired
for a whole month and I just thought
maybe from all the traveling on jetlag
whatever right and finds out that why I
had to go to Urgent Care and [ __ ] cuz
one day i JK news there would like go
home Joe you just [ __ ] up and I was
like I didn't I don't know like I'm just
my energy was down mm-hmm so I went to
Urgent Care endure like oh yeah you've
been dealing with the bacterial
infection for the last month here's some
antibiotics take some antibiotics right
so I'm feeling better and then I'm doing
the Tony Robbins seminar thing I'm out
in Florida I'm room a ting with with
Aaron and Aaron's been sick he's got
like bronchitis or some [ __ ] like every
night he's like you know and I'm a poor
Aaron man and I'm like I can't sleep you
know what let me just turn on some
[ __ ] white noise waterfall some
[ __ ] dolphins and [ __ ] you know I'm
listening to it and I was like I fall
asleep with a uh-huh and then the
Dolphins like so the whole time I'm fine
my Energy's good you know and then I
start feeling some internal bleeding bro
like I'm [ __ ] [ __ ] and like
Bloods coming out of my [ __ ]
and I'm all like man it's probably the
antibiotics cuz I read it up yeah
medicine harsh medicine [ __ ] kills
your guts that [ __ ] happens
I was dealing with that
and then after that I get back and then
uh I get a fever on on Wednesday morning
I mean Thursday morning before JK news
and I'm like [ __ ] man
and I take a hot-ass shower I sweat that
[ __ ] out I feel great I get into
the office I kill it do some JK news I
go out and I keep pressing my body like
I just keep going out keep working
don't stop and then Gina's brain we're
supposed to shoot that whole [ __ ]
week I'm done I can't even wake up like
I feel like your body was getting better
and you were like I'm good and then you
went to do the JK news thing and it just
[ __ ] it again [ __ ] it dude yeah and
then so from Sunday till last night I've
been coughing all night I don't even
sleep it like every 10 minutes on my and
I just wake up and I'm like [ __ ] now I'm
like Erin oh [ __ ] so you got you got the
bronchitis from Erin yeah and like
phlegm all kinds of [ __ ] I'm out here
like you know that Neddy thing the neti
pot oh yeah I'm not here like squeezing
my nose like with water and then the
what goes into one nose goes out the
other nose like like clearing out my
nasal cavities I'm out I'm doing
whatever the [ __ ] I can man taking hot
baths whatever I'm like tonight I'm
gonna sleep take some nyquil and [ __ ] I
don't like taking medicine
I believe that my body should [ __ ] [ __ ]
up I'll be like [ __ ] this disease we're
all like you know I believe in medicine
I take a [ __ ] ton of medicine what a man
I don't I don't that's why I hated
taking antibiotics I'm like [ __ ] I'm a
[ __ ]
I need this my immune system should [ __ ]
some [ __ ] up you know do you have the
video to vaccinate your kids right oh
hell yeah we get the bubonic plague and
[ __ ] they're not that strong
what is that whole non vaccination thing
about because I know it got really
popular because of that one former
Playboy model what was her name
I don't know she anybody that takes
science advice from a Playboy models a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
but she was the one that I think she was
the huge catalyst or the person that was
talking about how vaccinations has a
direct link to autism yeah I mean there
has been some I guess studies in the
pseudoscience world that says that you
know these this is what's causing autism
but I think what's causing autism is
women having babies at a later age and
they're also not very healthy and fit
and yeah I think I read that those those
studies were all non conclusive but
people were running with it like it was
facts and so there was I think it was at
Disneyland I forgot what it was but you
know Disneyland's a hub for a lot of
people around the world
just [ __ ] it's like immigrant Vegas
yeah so they come out they're not
vaccinated they came in and a bunch of
kids walked away with like the measles
or the mumps it was like some kind of
[ __ ] 18th century disease because
they didn't vaccinate their kids
bubonic is like [ __ ] [ __ ] vaccinate
your kids man I believe in that [ __ ] I
just think so as much as I can I want my
body to to fight it off with the immune
system as much as possible but you know
it goes with being healthy as well like
I can't pretend that it's gonna fight it
off if I'm not sleeping if I'm not
eating yeah if I'm straining myself and
stressing myself out I got the flu over
the winter right I don't think I've had
the flu since I don't know I was a
little kid I thought I was gonna die i
legit thought I was gonna die really I I
I was like you know what I have cancer
like this is what I was in so much
[ __ ] pain cuz I uh
so I by my best friend's a doctor so I
called them up all right texted him I
was like yo man like I'm dying dude like
what's happening he goes I think you had
the flu I was like this is what the
[ __ ] flu feels like just do puke and
diarrhea at the same time so I had a
crazy high fever my body was shivering
and I was sweating through my blanket
like I was constantly sweating so I
couldn't get I was hot and I was called
same time and it felt like the marrow in
my bones were hurting Oh time I moved
like an inch my whole body would be at
severe so yeah I guess that's the flu so
I didn't know that and he was not pretty
bad he was telling me that people still
die from the flu till this day it's not
something that it's it what it's it's a
viral thing it's a virus and it mutates
every year and what the what the flu
medication does is that it takes the
previous flu right and then it tries to
develop a antibody or whatever antiviral
medication yeah
that and so but that's a hit or miss
because it'll mutate into something else
so it only protects you I don't know I'm
throwing out a remnant number maybe like
30 or 40 percent the way has it always
got to come around the same season to
know if I get what I don't see this
[ __ ] during summer like where
the [ __ ] does it go I got [ __ ] man and
so I went home and I remember I was
feeling sick the day before and I rested
just like you I was like I'm good so I
went on the plane but I put like a
little medical mask around in case I
don't want to get other people sick oh
you're so considerate yeah and so what
right when I got home my brother picked
me up from the airport and I had him
blast the heater in the car to like 90
degrees to her like even that cold
my brother was like dude I can't breathe
in here I was like I'm still freezing
body was shaking it was still shaking
cuz it was cold but when they touched my
head I had a huge fever so my buddy told
me that I have to take like Advil or
some type of uh some [ __ ] to bring my
tent down yeah so I took like a Avila
tile and I was in bed for six days
non-stop and I couldn't move and I was
losing my mind cuz I'm so in active now
yeah I have to move every day I feel
dude I've never worked out in like
almost a month I feel like [ __ ] day
three I took a walk around the block
just so I could get some air and I came
back in and I passed out yeah I'll just
so much paid dude I remember I was
coughing in the middle of the night I
got so frustrated I [ __ ] started
punching the [ __ ] out of my pillow and I
got up and I started doing pull-ups did
some push-ups and I was like [ __ ] man
I'm gonna work out this [ __ ]
respiratory disease to death go we know
when you stay active and you don't move
it feels like you're losing your [ __ ]
mind I think I actually had like ADHD I
was just too fat allow me to move and
that's what Muriel says she goes I think
you really did have 80 you do have ADHD
others now you're always fidgeting you
can't stop moving like if we're hanging
outside after we have dinner and we're
in the parking lot or something around
it [ __ ] I'm just moving around in
circles I'm like stepping back first
welcome to my wire now I'm you dude I
understand what it feels like when
you're at a funeral you can sit still
isn't it rough mmm I can't move I don't
[ __ ] oh my god man I feel like I I
legit felt like I was
in an asylum III want bodies just that's
going like this hmm
muscles like I understand why you wanted
to punch your pillow cuz that's what I
felt like I I just thought of punching
the [ __ ] out of my pillow I was like why
can't I breathe [ __ ]
she was so hard man like just sit in
there and just doing nothing but I found
some of the coolest things for breathing
like one is that that neti pot thing you
know I love that [ __ ] you saw you kiss
yeah it goes one one nose out the other
nose you know the the Vicks nasal yeah
you [ __ ] put it in your nose and you
breathe it and you get all this menthol
up your nasal cavity they have these
little Vicks shower tabs it's like it's
like it's like these little like
dissolvable pill like it's not a pills
like a big tab like that did you put it
a shower and then the [ __ ] water hits
it and then all that the vapor turned
into this being steamed is so nice
[ __ ] you see he's still dying to this
day it's crazy man
like I am I don't like being sick it's
one of those things that I just I don't
think I think when we do get six it's
like it's like a light cold or something
old might get a coffee here in there but
being like debilitated from being sick
is something like that doesn't happen to
me that's bad so I'm saying I thought I
was gonna die I was like a little [ __ ]
I still can't believe people die from
the flu to this day I did [ __ ]
theraflu and I call at the same time was
like this [ __ ] ain't working I had to
get a nyquil and then the funny thing is
I still refused to go to the doctor and
everyone's telling me go to the [ __ ]
doctor Joe they're just gonna give you
some medicine that's what I'm saying
what the [ __ ] are they gonna do they're
gonna get this that the scope and put it
on my chest and [ __ ] and tell me to
breathe take more [ __ ] temperature
maybe take a little blood man damn what
like if you if if it's if it's like
common symptoms they're just gonna gonna
give me like antibiotics or something
I'm like I just [ __ ] took antibiotics
yeah but you know yeah man I just
coughed too much that's it
yeah you set the rest up and sleep yeah
I'm not gonna go with a doctor [ __ ] that
that's the craziest thing well today
fellas people's girls we are going to do
a genius suggestion like this is like
one of those pop and things that you
guys you just want to hear other
people's problems uh to make you feel
better by using my favorite ones Matt
love it too because we all have like
crap
be situations and shitty live so let's
let's try to help each other out and I'd
like you when you guys give some advice
to in the comments to like I think some
y'all got some gems may I read some of
them yeah yeah some of you are really
[ __ ] dumb but that's a good like 90
percent that are really smart with their
advice and there's also the [ __ ]
trolls to that thing that they want to
take us down but [ __ ] you [ __ ]
yeah you getting taking [ __ ] down you
can take down my nuts down your mouth
yes I love the fans though the genius
brain fans are like one of the best ones
oh yeah they're very involved that's
what I that's what I like about them is
like they're involved in helping you
know each other and all that [ __ ] I read
the comments and it's like there's a lot
of intelligent fans out there I love it
so this uh this is actually a very
soulful on the patreon patreon people
always get first dibs if you guys write
down the issue that you want us to help
you with or suggest or just you know
have people listen to your problems be
specific about the situation and this
girl is very specific because she wrote
it whole anthology she's like my [ __ ]
don't get wet enough are you spit I use
everything No this podcast is brought to
you by fiber baby let's talk about
finding freelance talent for your
business or project finding the right
freelancer can be time-consuming
frustrating and expensive because look
you got to know where to find the talent
how much is going to cost and who knows
how are they gonna deliver it well
thanks to fiber finding the right
freelancer doesn't have to be a struggle
look fibrous marketplace helps you get
more done with less it connects you to
businesses with freelancers who offer
hundreds of digital services including
graphic design copywriting web
programming film editing and a whole
bunch more there's a lot of quality
talent on there that you can count on
I've used Fiverr personally for a lot of
my album covers whenever I do music and
the people that I find deliver great all
the stuff that they will deliver how
they're gonna deliver it and the time is
on there so you can best believe that
you keep people accountable on their
deliverables and they have ratings on
there too so you can see how dope they
are take five and check out fiverr.com
and you will receive 10% off your first
order by you
my code borane it's so easy don't waste
any more time and get the service you
deserve by going to F I ve are are.com
code brain fiber it starts here here we
have Christina she is a $50 lifetime
pledge shout-out to you why I love you
very much when I was single I probably
date you go you know sup hahahaha
you got money you got that spare money
thank you for supporting David so comedy
and the genius brain what is it about
women with money that's such a turn-on
like I don't even um I don't even want
them to pay for me I said I just like
the fact that they have money I didn't
earn money I know what you mean man like
I said member I told you about that
story about my buddy edrick who dated
that girl that was a gajillion err yeah
and he was like nah [ __ ] it and she had
big old titties Wow
he [ __ ] up dude she's a tease and
money she was cute and she was super
sweet I like a woman that knows how to
that she can pay for her own plane
ticket even though I'm gonna [ __ ] buy
it anyway yeah cuz I like to give like
the fact that I know she could pay for
that [ __ ] I like that I like it too
someone was my [ __ ] so Cristina oh this
was great I love this one how do I find
a support system oh this is a this is a
this is a this is the good one right
here and she's going into a personal
story so I've been struggling with
making friends ever since graduating
from college I'm almost 30 I still don't
have someone I can call a friend friend
I am I've tried apps bumble bumble BFF
Meetup weed three Pitou damn [ __ ]
friends huh you made a lot of or hey hey
veena et Cie volunteering and hobbies
but I haven't had any luck anyone who
shares a hobby with me lives either in
another state or another country I
realized the number one way for people
to socialize as an adult
is drinking but I don't drink alcohol
smoke weed or do drugs neither do we
cual hydrate not that much though I'm a
social drinker but we know how to make
friends mm-hmm the people at my work are
cliquey and it feels like high school
from my past experiences Church hasn't
been a good option hmm family isn't an
option since they only support me
when they benefit from my actions oh she
black - you ain't got a shin parish this
type I haven't we were late I have a
narcissistic family and they are part of
the reason why I've dealt with
depression all my life I was clinically
diagnosed my first year of college and
spent and still spending my time
learning coping skills all of us are
there - in total I've been seeing a
therapist on and off for the past ten
years due to finances my only support
system in my life were my dog and cat
growing up but they died humansgirl yeah
but they died recently oh that's what
the [ __ ] dog oh we could make a movie
about you I know dude I called a walk
not to remember I felt alone all of my
life ouch
and I saw a therapist earlier this year
for grief and depression counseling the
last thing my therapist told me before
the end of our session was to keep going
to events and hobbies that I'm
specifically interested in and I'll
hopefully find a support system the
don't the don't look for people focus on
doing what you love and the people will
come I put myself out there but can't
find anyone to connect with I go to
circus shows glassblowing classes damage
you as a interesting what did you Barnum
and Bailey Circus Circus like what no
where the [ __ ] do you find circus shows
I Vegas oh that's [ __ ] crazy
I remember the commercials no they're
like the circus biggest circus in town
is coming to you and then it's like do
you remember those commercial
it would tour a different cities yeah it
was like bombing Barnum and Bailey and
Barnum & Bailey yeah what useful you say
glassblowing classes are you interested
in going to the gym comedy shows when
they are in my area baking desserts walk
around you you really did try some
options here man you know what it you
know what I think it is what's up
because man all right how do I say this
in the least Dickus way in the whole
entire world
if you're trying that hard or ste to
make friends it might be a you problem
and not of them problem mmm right like
it's to me like it's not difficult
making friends yeah but then mmm when
you're specifically looking for a
support system what you're looking for
is more of them to support you not
giving ya so you got to change your
whole perspective here the feeling of I
need support from these people it's like
I get it like we all need a support
system but you have to cultivate that
over time a support a support network
comes from like going through [ __ ]
together yeah like I think you have to
go you can't [ __ ] on the first date
right you got to go through stages like
you can't automatically start expecting
someone to support you right after you
meet them not saying that you do this
but in the verbage this is what I'm
getting is like you're looking for a
support group or whatever and I think
that a lot of people don't want to get
into a lot of drama or deep [ __ ] they
just want surface [ __ ] they just want to
hang out blow some glass together oh
cool cool blow some glass yeah good blow
some glass for like 10 sessions no
smoking broken windows and don't [ __ ]
grab some beer or whatever and then talk
about your favorite pets yeah I really
wonder if that's how it is in your case
right because you know Joe and I
actually talked about this in our
interpersonal relationships when we talk
about people who really they [ __ ] on the
first date not literally right it's it's
more like you you I think girls do this
a lot guys are very pessimistic in this
kind of case but I think girls do this a
lot where you guys have seen this on
Instagram or or some [ __ ] which is
actually a reflection of their life that
I see a lot they meet this girl they
have a hobby in mind right they go oh
[ __ ] you do that I do that too what's up
then a couple of weeks later yo besties
and they start you know they're drinking
margaritas together besties this is my
best gal for life and kisses it's like
yo you're [ __ ] on the first date and
then I'm two weeks later they go hate
each other they go I can't believe this
[ __ ] did that of course you can't [ __ ]
you don't [ __ ] know her yeah you
don't know each other yet you guys
[ __ ] on the first date they get too
excited of from the bonding but you
needed that you mean people need a vet
that's nothing like I have some long
lasting friendships and there is drama
there is ups and downs there is things
that happen but at the end of the day
the loyalty that I have with them is is
very irreplaceable yeah like we do have
a really strong network of people that
we can count on they're not always gonna
be the greatest they're sometimes
annoying but still I have a support
system but that shit's built over years
grow like you got to build that [ __ ]
over time and I don't even we don't even
get deep into friendship until like
years later yeah but if you're pouring
out your emotions on the first day or
two people gonna think you nuts
yeah you really will and that's what my
friend okay so here's the thing
Mike one of my cousins right [ __ ]
bless her soul this this girl is so warm
and inviting
you can literally pour out your [ __ ]
soul to her the first day you meet her
and she will accept usual listen to you
she does not realize that the world is
not her so she's out there doing that
with everyone she can't [ __ ] make a
connection to make friends and we're all
telling her chill yeah you got a you got
a you gotta ease into the friendship
yeah she's like not wanna connect deeply
with people and I'm like I see that you
do and I see that you're willing to give
and you're willing to receive but you
have to understand that other people
aren't ready for that and you scare them
when you talk about [ __ ] marital
problems or whatever on the first day
you guys hang out and you're crying to
them for two hours they think you're
nuts and then it's like it's amazing
that she can receive that for other
people and that that might be her case
like she might be very open and okay and
other people like she would receive them
but what if she's like too forceful with
the friendship who knows but I think
that the stages is like you go do you
find common hobbies you do have common
interests you hang out you play like on
a surface level you crack jokes you have
a pleasant encounter you like this
person I like this person because we can
always skate together or whatever right
and then you move on oh [ __ ] I find out
that he has a brother in prison I got a
brother in prison we can bond over that
sad [ __ ] right or whatever it is it
could be like hey seems like we both had
a car accident together traumatic car
accident it could
negative but generally you want to have
Pleasant encounters with people and
build it over time and then there's the
whole sacrifice part of it of like oh
I'm down and out I need some help can
you support me yeah whatever like but if
you come straight out the bat and you're
like yo I got these struggles I need a
[ __ ] pour out yeah that's I mean
that's really hard to write because I
also think that you're you're giving an
apple and you're expecting an apple back
but you keep getting an orange right and
that's just not how the world works it's
like the same concept with doing good
deeds in this world there's a lot of
people who are great great people like
your friend who's so gracious and they
give and they give and they give but
when sometimes when they don't receive
what they give out they're like well
that's [ __ ] up well that's just not
how things work yeah when you do a good
deed you just do a good deed and you
don't expect things in return and in
this case - for you maybe because I
don't really know you like that you're
going on this stuff to find a really
hardcore connection but are these other
people that you meet willing to do that
as well maybe they're not like joe said
maybe there's yourself they just want to
gloat blow some glass baby you know
let's go blow some glass and they're
just having a good time and then you're
expecting something more out of a
friendship that either one hasn't had
the time to develop that way or number
two that's not really what they're
looking for yeah deep emotional
connections I think are cultivated over
time a lot of done in spurts yeah
they're not done in intense passionate
deep like encounters I think that's more
of a romantic thing that's it those for
[ __ ] sure like even if we wanted to
relate to ourselves to like you know I
think a lot of times people look at your
my friendship yeah and Bard's and they
go like I want that we I've known these
guys for 10 years now we didn't even
start doing business together until like
four or five years ago it yeah it took a
while like this this stuff isn't easy
yet meeting people and having a good
time is easy but it looks like what
you're looking for is somebody to count
on to be you know your point of
accountability to be your best friend
yeah I bet that doesn't happen that
quick and also too if you're putting
yourself in a position where you're
coming up and then maybe you're spilling
your heart out to this person you're
probably scaring them away I would
be freaked the [ __ ] out I would if I
came out and I was just here to watch
some clowns you know I mean like
juggling [ __ ] yeah else and you're like
well my dog in my cat died I've been
like [ __ ] what the [ __ ] can I hug you
and cry and [ __ ] they're all juggling
like can I cry with you right now and
then you turned unless she's like I'm
just trying to enjoy this [ __ ] lion
show right now I don't know it's weird -
it's like well when can i when can i
open up and that's the part that you're
gonna have to feel that and also to
figure out who you should open up to and
should you even at this point yeah right
cuz I wouldn't just open up to somebody
about all my stuff I mean for me because
it's for entertainment purposes I'm very
comfortable with who I am and I have a
strong group of friends I tell people
all about my [ __ ] but there's still like
this thirty forty percent that I keep
between me and Joe yeah I keep between
me and Bart me and Mary oh there's
levels to this [ __ ]
hell yeah any levels to like we always
say - there's there's the homie
there's the homie and there's the homie
homie yeah get out there's a friend
homie homie homie homie it's all at
different stages man let me leave you
the rest of your stuff - well and I mean
also it's so difficult because I don't
really know her what she's going through
it could be that she's too thirsty or it
could just genuinely be she's into a
deity area maybe - yeah cuz I know that
people in small towns they're limited
man like Bo's like she grew up in a
small town and she was limited to the
owl that's right and I have family
members too that are like a little too
intelligent for the community that they
live in and I'm like but if your genius
ass just [ __ ] move - I don't know
Boston or like the Silicon Valley or if
you were and around a bunch of other
people that were like-minded that might
work - you also check this out dude that
you're actually right because she wrote
here she goes one of my hobbies is
aerial arts but there isn't any one in
my area that I found that shares that
the only hobby that's in my area seems
our board games D&D LARPing and geeks
beer trivia I live in a low-income
blue-collar area yeah so not much to do
I've tried to get into a low-income
blue-collared nerds
Dungeons and Dragons and [ __ ] yeah
that's kind of rough yeah that's pretty
much my only hobby where there's a
chance to meet people in real life my
other hobbies are art animation not
anime I grow out of it
storytelling travel storytelling
traveling an illustration I'm not
financially stable to mope so your honor
right it's her area it's different area
yeah yeah I mean it's probably a mixture
of both right like yeah sometimes it's
also like this right how important is a
social life to you and finding this
group to be connected with because if
it's that important maybe you should
move and find a place that fits you
better because we that's one of the
things I say too like we live in one of
the greatest [ __ ] countries in the
world where you can be whoever the [ __ ]
you want you can literally be a
completely gay dude in West LA run
around in your underwear with the flag
and just [ __ ] parade with no
restrictions and everybody loves you
like a [ __ ]
during the day he's a [ __ ] lawyer
yeah or that same guy could be in the
Bible Belt small town where he feels
ridiculed and he's just like I gotta get
out of this mess you know like you know
it's like but if if only he lived in
West LA he would have been himself yeah
this podcast is brought to you by
attitude my friends if you are wondering
why I get the best sleep of my life it's
not only because I have a really
comfortable bed is because I have the
sheets to match and my attitude sheets
are amazing I wake up feeling great
because I only want to caress my
beautiful supple Korean skin with these
lovely sheets it has been the best
investment that I have ever invested
into my sleep yes my friends added two
sheets have a couple of things about why
I love them so much number one as I
mentioned the comfort attitude is
feathery soft super super silky I'm
talking about it feels like I'm being
caressed by a thousand baby kittens all
at once yes I love them they're cooling
organic clean bamboo is what they're
made out of and it's extremely
breathable it regulates your temperature
to improve your quality of sleep if you
did not know already so why not try edit
these amazing sheets have a 30-day
risk-free trial and if you're not fully
satisfied you can return your sheets for
a full refund
they even cover shipping on returns and
it's you sheets they're soft as silk
breathable as linen but at the price of
cotton you're going to love them and
when you support our sponsors you
support our show and right now my
listeners will get 20% off their sheet
set and free shipping just Tex brain 2 6
4 - 0 0 0 the only way to get 20% off
your set of entity sheets and free
shipping is to Tex brain to 64000 that's
B our a I n 2 6 4 - 0 0 0 I would like
to say this too for her because she says
that she doesn't feel financially stable
to move I think that's a lot of people
when they when there's this huge leap
that they have to take right it's hard
it's it's hard because it seemed that a
point right now where you have tried so
many different options to make this
situation work and there is no guarantee
that if you move into a different place
that you'll be able to find a new
connection with different people that
have your interest that's a very very
scary and brave thing to do because
there is no you're right there is no
guarantee that if you leave from this
point you go somewhere else you might
find that you're now in a worse
financial situation and you still
haven't been able to find or connect to
anybody else which by the way if you
come to LA a lot of people find that - a
lot of people have that happen to them
because they have this certain idea of
what la is la is and what they want from
it and when they come here they go oh
[ __ ] I'm actually kind of lonely out
here yeah a lot of people in this city
are very very lonely because they're too
busy trying to be famous
exactly so for you if you want to be out
of your situation and I know that it's I
don't know what your financial situation
is but if I were to put myself and the
reason why I feel like I'm okay saying
this is because I grew up [ __ ] dirt
poor I grew up dirt a Spore my parents
were [ __ ] dirt poor - we went up from
being [ __ ] dirt poor to being a
decent middle-class right like lower
middle class really lower middle class
and in order for me to move to this city
I had to work three jobs I saved up a
[ __ ] ton of stuff and I cut out a lot of
Mike my interpersonal relationships you
made a big leap of faith yeah I had five
hundred bucks in my [ __ ] bank account
when I came to LA
so you know there yeah a lot of things
do seem impossible because it's very
daunting but if it's something that you
really need and that you really want you
can do it and there is a high chance of
failure but I think that when you say
you're financially unstable I do believe
you because so is I but if it's if it's
killing you and you've tried out all
your options what do you have to lose by
trying to move out somewhere else yeah
if you already broke what's the
difference
now you'd be broke with dope friends
yeah you're either broken alone or you
move to a different place and you're
broke but now you found cool friends
yeah and it's and it's a hard situation
to be and especially for a lot of us to
when we're trying to work we're trying
to kind of like pick up our pieces it's
it's hard cuz it's like well I got to do
this without a support group well you
know not to sound negative you don't
have a support group here anyway so you
might as well just move somewhere else
to see what you can do with it yeah I
think man it really depends on what you
want out of a support group to like some
people just want that tribe that that
clique right yeah but there comes its
own set of problems when you're too damn
close with people too you have to
understand there's a balance man like
people think it's all [ __ ] dope it is
better when you have support when versus
if you don't but man it's not the grass
is not greener you know you have other
problems you have to carry on aside from
your own now mm-hmm
you might have you having the greatest
day of your [ __ ] life and then your
friend calls in it's like this [ __ ]
happened and it brings you down I you
know and just reading this - I mean
let's let's complete the rest of what
she was saying she goes the few friends
that I've known since high school have
slowly cut me out of their lives because
they're making their own families
spending time with their significant
others or taking care of their elderly
parents most people my age already have
a family and good people
Oh most people they have a good family
and some good support so they don't look
to expand it but if not people had kids
at a young age so no going to an event
last minute without finding a sitter
I need social contact in my life and
talking online to people isn't cutting
it anymore I feel like I'm sleeping back
slipping back into my depression I don't
know if you can help but any advice is
appreciated yeah yeah I like I said from
from from the situation it seems like
you're you're asking
a lot from these really quick moments
it's a lot to ask for to find that human
contact if you just needed human contact
you're actually getting the human
contact so that's not what you're
actually looking for you're looking for
a deep connection with a small group of
people they're looking for love outside
and what it sounds like
is she needs a little bit of self-love
mmm it sounds like she's trying to
really have feel significant through
these people giving her attention yes in
that sense yeah yeah my friends are busy
now they're they're busy building their
own family they're doing this and that
they don't have time for me
so you do have some friends Jim right I
would say hey my friends are busy with
their baby I'm a single lonely man let
me call him up a you need you need
somebody to cook for you you need you
need somebody to come over and fun can
help you out that's how you build a bond
yeah is you go to you give that's what I
do is I give I give a lot and I can
inject myself and and not only be
helpful I'll [ __ ] come over and be
like I'll [ __ ] clean up or [ __ ]
cook or hang out or what do you need me
to do and on top of that I get time to
talk to mom and whatever and that to me
is good it's it's a-you I find more
fulfillment in giving than I do taking
right so instead of being like man they
can't find a babysitter and hang out
with me you go to them I go well what
what can I do to help them out yeah it
seems like just from that point of view
- it seems like you actually do have
people who are within your support group
but they're just not molding to your
lifestyle well when people have kids
that's what happens yeah they get busy
yeah Barton Barton Gio they have a kid
right now - when we hang out
Tycho's there I mean I'll put it to you
like this I'm not saying this was a
great thing that me and Jo did but we
went on a Hawaii vacation trip and
Christina Bart NGO both came along with
their kids yeah I mean we had to make
adjustments for ourselves from what we
normally would do but because we wanted
them there and it was fun they brought
their kids we made a few adjustments and
it was okay so for you in your case - if
you do have people that you said that
are you're really close friends but it
seems like they're starting their family
I mean unless they're cutting you out
then yeah it does require for you to
take a little bit away from yourself and
to them mm-hmm when Gio first had her
kid the first thing I did I went to
their house and I cook them dinner yeah
like these are the adjustments that I
make we're not gonna go out to
Shinsengumi anymore and you know we're
not gonna go eat dinner until like 11:00
11:00 p.m. no I am in the morning we
were not we're not doing that anymore
yeah you know we made those adjustments
and is still okay yeah I think what's
happening is you know she feels alone
she needs her needs met right so what
what's happening is is is obviously when
you feel pressed to the corner you start
thinking about yourself yeah I'm not
saying there's anything wrong with that
like we all do it we all we all get to
this point where we're like I need my
needs met someone has to love me like
that's what it sounds like
yeah but what needs to happen if you
want to feel that kind of love or if you
want that connection is you need to go
outward not inward so when you swap it
around and make it about giving and it
has to be unconditional it can't be like
I'm doing this [ __ ] for you and you
don't do anything back for me right it
has to be like this is my friends
they're busy I want to have their back
that is a support system my friends are
busy because they just they're popping
out kids and you know they're barely
sleeping but I want time with them and I
want to be a part of their lives and I
want to be a part of the kid's life I
want to be auntie
that is how you build a support system
yeah
not they're busy I don't want to bother
them let me do my own thing they can't
come party with me whatever yeah and by
the way to your 30 I'm 31 I'm only a
year older than you so all my friends
now I think have them have kids yeah so
but we still adjust to their lifestyle
to maintain the friendship yeah and it
was never a problem I never felt like
they didn't they weren't there for me no
I know we just had to make adjustment
they just have time they can be there
for me when it now works for them
because they had this little human they
have to take care of ya and in mine and
Bart's relationship changed dramatically
after taiking because we just don't have
that time to just chill anymore mm-hmm
but I don't take that personal I don't
take I just see it as a
evolution of our dynamic it's a new
chapter it's a new chapter right and you
know if I had a kid at the same time I
probably I probably would be able to
bond with him or whatnot but it's just a
different chapter we're gonna take a
break maybe I'll come back or some I'll
hang out when I can but it's a different
dynamic it's just it's just completely
different yeah so I mean it seems like
your problem can be helped with a little
bit of a shift of perspective and
understanding what you really want out
of these interpersonal relationships and
we're doing our best to help understand
your situation you did a great job in
writing that stuff out but yeah let's
let's see if you do have those really
good friends in your life and maybe in
your case it takes a little bit of a
perspective flip to say like hey these
relationships are different now and now
it's evolved differently or we could say
this where maybe you're expecting too
much out of these new connections like
the connections that you had with the
people that had kids prior to their
children but remember when you had those
friends since you were younger that took
time to develop yeah and now you're
expecting that same type of support and
understanding from these new people and
you're not gonna get it from them it's
just not gonna happen
and then the friends that she's probably
cultivated over time that had that are
starting to families that are in that
stage it would be such a waste to throw
away that connection like she does it
sounds like she does have friends mm-hmm
because originally it sounded like she
had no [ __ ] friends yeah and she's
going to glassblowing class like some
[ __ ] blowing some pipes [ __ ] she has
a bunch of hippie ass people licensed
owners she's like [ __ ] man
have I stooped to this level where I'm
trying to make a best friend out of out
of a glassblowing class you looking back
just like you know what the [ __ ] am i
doing I'm over here LARPing with these
[ __ ] [ __ ] fireball fireball
shield shield but when in reality it
does have friends yeah they're there
they're there you just you know I think
maybe you want more right and I think
it's all about the cultivating of
friends like for example when I realized
that the stages will be different
between some of me and my like friends
like at
like bard or whatever their availability
or whatever then I just started
cultivating my relationship with like
David or like my buddy Alex or like
someone who was at my stage yeah who has
the time to go let's go grab some dinner
yeah whatever and you can you know it's
not like cheating on friends or anything
like that I just think there's different
stages let me let me summarize this
right first you have an acquaintance
an acquaintance is someone you meet you
kind of like each other or you know of
them and they're cool right and you
might have a common interest and a lot
of people tend to just like each other's
personality presence they make you laugh
whatever it is let's go grab some drinks
and talk and you just [ __ ] talk about
life or talk about other people or
whatever it is you do and you enjoy
someone's company right that's the first
stage and then or the second stage
becomes friendship and that's when
you're frequently doing that and you
might see them once a week once every
other week whatever and you start
getting closer to their proxemics right
and then you might hang out with them
like every other day or even you know
every day or whatever that's when you
start getting into that zone of like a
good home ER like a good friend like a
best friend or whatever and over time
you have to go through these stages if
you can't get past the first stage
there's something going on I don't know
what it is but for me if I don't pass
that first stage with someone from
acquaintances or like he's a classmate
or or she's she's a part of my
glassblowing class and I got her number
or whatever and if I can't pass that
stage of like hanging out with them and
enjoying their company and feeling
comfortable I think that's the keyword
comfortable around them then it's either
that it didn't match or they don't like
me or I don't you know whatever it is
it's just not a connection you know so
connections can't be forced
you just got to naturally relax into it
be yourself enjoy their company and then
take it to the next stage take it to the
next stage but usually these things take
months we have years to build yeah it
doesn't happen overnight you know I
think it happens when you're younger
overnight because you ain't doing [ __ ]
like when you're in high school yeah
I'll call it joint [ __ ] you ain't really
doing [ __ ]
you're just you your job is to make
friends you go to school
[ __ ] study you're talking to people
in class you have a best friend because
you hang out with them every [ __ ] day
after school you go hang out every day
that's why some people they make friends
in high school and they become lifelong
friends you know because you have so
many hours together and then in college
same [ __ ] like you have a lot of time
aside from studying you have a lot of
time to just sit down and do jack
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know and then it gets
harder the older you get because you
don't have time you have families that
you're building or whatever but it's
still possible it's not impossible you
just got to get better at social skills
and like connecting quicker you know and
if I know that you you wrote that you're
dealing with your depression
and I think that your depression might
be hanging on the fact that you're that
you really really want to to make this
social connection and you really think
that that's going to fix that and I
don't think that's what's gonna happen
nope like it's just not you got to love
yourself first and foremost because if
you're constantly seeking validation and
acceptance and love from other people
it's like chasing an Instagram like mmm
it's never enough you know well
shoutouts to the genius brain I hope
that really does help you out like I
said this is an advice these are just
suggestions so Kristina hope that helped
you out and um shoutouts did the
glassblowing and stuff like appreciate
that the circus the circus stuff is
pretty fun no the circus of the Barnum &
Bailey [ __ ] but yeah that that that was
really great man
I hope helps y'all Kristina well guys
that wraps up this episode that was fast
I was fast man people keep saying they
want longer episodes for these yeah but
you know we we we knocked that bad boy
out son but that wraps up this episode
for the genius suggestion I hope you
guys really enjoyed that remember if you
guys want us to help you out talk about
stuff hit us up man because originally
when we were doing this it was it was
like free for all topics but I think
people really do like the pen
pointed topics that we could I could
just do I do to like it helps out a lot
of these because yeah it's almost like
I'm talking to a friend yeah and as I'm
saying this [ __ ] out loud I'm like I
have friends that can benefit from this
[ __ ] Oh a hundred percent man and so for
you you're out there and I don't know
where you're at maybe you're in in Iowa
or something like that while she's like
Las Vegas no wonder you're a Vegas man
people out there just to get drunk
against some random [ __ ] come on now
it's not that that's not maybe that's
why she's going to all these circuses
and I was like oh of course you got
glassblowing in circus this baby circus
Olay yeah well we will catch you all
next time remember every Thursday that's
where you get those genius suggestions
with me and Joe and then you'll see
genius brain on Sundays you could catch
us on all audio platforms we're talking
about Spotify stitcher
whatever whatever stuff that you see out
there some of these episodes might be 40
minutes long some of them might be 45 to
an hour to an hour and a half who knows
but we are there for your commute and
for your daily entertainment appreciate
you all see you all next time
blow some glass baby to the loo [ __ ]
face